soit continuer la partie
soit affirme nul
et ne pas se mettre dans une situation
où kasparov pourrais je la jouais entre
guillemets à la pendule
en profitant du fait que cramique n'a
plus que 37 minutes pour arriver au 40e
coup contre 55 à kaspar ont fait
maintenant ça commence à être non
négligeable il faut faire attention
granic essaie de trouver des idées
travnik essaie de trouver des idées
peut-être que kasparov a d'autres idées
par exemple déjoué tour à 4 pour mettre
la pression sur les quatre foulées cette
voie là j'ai 7,6 jouer tout de suite
chroniqueur ménagé cette la question
maintenant que se pose qui se posent à
kasparov c est ce que kaspar veut faire
nul en rejouant le cavalier sur la case
c5 ou bien vont-ils jouer le coup tours
1 1 à 4 éventuellement pour faire une
pression directe sur le pion des quatre
aidé en cela ne son cavalier en b3 c'est
possible
c'est la question que l'on est en droit
de se poser actuellement dans cette
partie en tout cas kramix élevé ça veut
dire qu'il n'a pas l'intention de
proposer du d'accepter une nulle tout de
suite sinon il serait resté en attendant
le coup de kasparov probablement et une
éventuelle proposition de nul de
kasparov la sica sparrow joue cavalier
c5
la question c'est est-ce que gravelines
va rejouer faut ensuite répétant deux
fois la même position et donc propose
implicitement kasparov de répéter les
coups et d'accepter la partie nulle ou
bien sûr qu'aller csn cramique va-t-il
essayer une autre solution comme le coup
au 6 e 5 qui alors possible
que ce parent
en réflexion cette position et sport
peut jouer probablement aussi le coût
pour 1,4 mais on se heurte au rhino
bouton raquette au kung fu 17 attaquants
la tour et développant le fou pour
ensuite se poster sur les casses c6 ou
la case b5
donc ça n'a pas l'air ça a pas l'air
très très bon le coutour à 4 cause du
fou c'est 8 qui viendrait sur la case 17
la position que vous voyez sur
l'échiquier
les flèches
il a kasparov
dans de grandes réflexions est-ce qu'il
va répéter les coups dans ce cas on
n'aura pas droit aujourd'hui à une
partie vraiment intéressante on va-t-il
essayer de trouver un plan pour
continuer à augmenter son avantage et
dont je crois stéphane que nous allons
assister à une nullité comme tu les
aimes c'est à dire une nullité sans
combat une partie pacifiste jouer entre
entre amis qui se termine par une partie
du c'est possible en tout cas d'éric as
part of a la balle dans son camp
ici rien ne dit qu'il a envie de
continuer cependant cram nick ayrton une
petite pression autant il lui reste que
36 minutes pour jouer 28 coups et c'est
pas forcément facile tout à fait c'est
pour ça que cette chronique maintenant
va accepter la partie nulle et que
kasparov n'aura encore rien réussi à
montrer avec les pièces blanches et qui
va probablement encore souffrir mardi
avec un kramnik encore plus affûtée
affûté
aucun dommage que crâne n'ont pas réussi
hier à marquer le point bas sinon
kasparov était vraiment vraiment très
très belle on l'a kasparov il nous fait
du cinéma mais on sait très bien qu'il
va répéter les cours il n'y a aucun
suspense
caracas port va jouer qu'à laisser 5 va
dire nulle cramique faire infléchir et
va dire oui c'est hautement probable en
tout cas on ne voit pas comment gao
comment et surtout pourquoi gary
kasparov continuera cette partie si on
regarde objectivement tous les facteurs
de cette position qu'est ce qu'on voit
stéphane on peut le pointer les noirs
ont plus d espace les noirs ont la paire
de fou alors que les blancs eux n'ont
pas grand chose
pas grand chose de concret effectivement
faudrait que ses parents soient vraiment
fatigué de la partie d'hier est donc on
va se reposer mais malheureusement ça
fait une occasion manquée avec les
blancs une occasion de plus à l'est non
mais tout à fait tout à fait dans mais
il ne faut pas gâcher des blancs dans ce
match puisque évidemment il n'y a aucun
doute là dessus
les joueurs lorsqu'ils conduiront les
pièces blanches que ce soit cas ce
programme d'icc ne perdrons pratiquement
jamais là qu'on démarre cette semaine
comme la première
kasparov tente une nouvelle ouverture
cette fois ils n'arrivent pas à passer
du tout comme dimanche dernier et la
cram nick va encore marquer le point
noir ni élevé caspar ans ne passera
toujours pas la même ouverture jeudi
prochain voilà et quand il va rater le
guen samedi
si j'ai la semaine prochaine et ainsi de
suite voilà ça nous aurons quatre séries
comme celle ci puisque le match et en 16
parties des séries de quatre 4 x 4 ça
fait 16 et donc 4 0 pour cramique 4-0
pour chronique en fin de match avec
quatre bien manquer donc
pour vladimir kramnik également c'est
dommage ça ferait ça aurait pu faire un
beau score un score de 12 à 4 et ça ne
fera qu'un score de 10 à 6
mais ce n'est pas grave puisque ici nous
sommes en train de regarder garry
kasparov qui réfléchit qui n'a pas l'air
de trouver grand-chose gala aujourd'hui
d'assez ici kasparov répète les coups on
aura une toute petite partie qui va
faire 23 ou 24 août et qui donc
s'achèvera par un résultat nul
quand chrome nickel et blanc c'est quand
même des partis plus fight risques et
oui la butte kasparov qui se transforme
petit à petit avec la géante karpov il
ce que transforme en karpov la casse par
en fait ça sent la fin de règne
kasparov est clairement sur la
descendante au début du troisième
millénaire
c'est difficile kasparov in the box
vladimir kramnik la nouvelle étoile
montante à noter comme stéphane ce qui
est tout à fait incroyable c'est que
kramnik a du mal à être numéro 2 mondial
il est en concurrence avec canon déchire
off qui semble jouer à peu près aussi
bien cuit
sauf qu'ils prennent des raclées raclée
contre kasparov puisque concurrence n'a
jamais gagné et un hollande en a gagné
quelques unes mais il en score je crois
négatif de 17 à 3 il me semble voilà
c'est exactement ça c'est énorme s'est
dit cette perte et trois gains voilà et
shirov c'est carrément alors on ne
compte plus les pertes mais non on
compte les gains il n'y en a pas au real
a pas de gain et n pertes avec n
relativement grand tout à fait
relativement ici
travnik est donc le seul apparemment sur
le paysage mondial échiquéen le pm à
pouvoir inquiéter garry kasparov pme
erika soir entre directeur l'écho aussi
qu est une étoile montante des échecs
qui est plus jeune que kramnik il a 21
ans peter l'écho ayants droit c'est un
joueur extrêmement forts qui a battu en
match le champion du monde officiel de
la fidh et par le score sans appel de
trois victoires à zéro sur six parties
soit 4 est bien est mis quatre emmy un
ennemi mais surtout trois victoires à
zéro
trois gammes avec les blancs ça ce qui
prouve aussi que la championne du monde
de la fidl n'est peut-être pas tout à
fait le meilleur joueur du monde et que
peter l'écho est très fort il a encore
démontré notamment afin notamment à
francfort où il a battu kasparov en
partie rapide
il aurait dû le battre deux fois il n'a
fait qu'un crédit sur deux met donc
kasparov faire l'écho mais quand même
quand même stéphane non mais parce que
ces tensions la kasparov est en train
d'être dominés poids élevé si on regarde
ces derniers tournois il les a tous
gagnés
oui mais à gagner encore une fois mais
il n'a pas il n'a pas gagné contre
kramnik il a fait deux nuls
linarès il les a gagné parce qu'en fait
il est plus fort contre une opposition
variés semble-t-il parce qu'il à redire
que kasparov était une sorte d'écrin ce
matin voilà kasparov saurine un écrase
patate effectivement que ça en batterie
les plus faibles avec une grande
facilité mais aurait du mal contre les
plus forts notamment contre le brésil
est donc ce qui prouve que la formule
des tournois ne détermine pas le
meilleur joueur du monde mais le
meilleur joueur de tournoi c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai le
champion du monde est communément
désignée par celui qui bat tous ses
adversaires en match pour l'instant
c'était castorf incontestablement icici
cramique l'emportent ce sera vraiment
historique
ce sera historique ce sera la fin n'est
pas vrai un drap que faudra que kramnik
confirme dans un autre match puisqu'on
sait que kramnik pour l'instant n'avait
pas réussi à démontrer des choses un
match mais peut-être ce match contre
kasparov la finit par le motiver ou
c'est qu'il a changé notamment sa
manière de vivre ça me titille les un
peu plus sportif en tout cas il est
moins drogué crainte des faits qui
buvait beaucoup et qui fumait pas mal
aussi ça me tillie vers d'autres revenus
à une manière de vie beaucoup plus saine
et ça a l'air de lui réussir un kramnik
vladimir kramnik ne fumerai plus ne
boirai plus frank rich bien aux échecs
aussi que linares le plus grand tournoi
du monde qui a lieu en espagne chaque
année et pour lequel nous avons fait un
reportage disponible dans diagonale
puisque nous étions allés en espagne et
loi pour faire ce reportage
il n'en reste a été gagné par kasparov à
égalité avec chroniques
effectivement effectivement le
chroniquer kasparov premier ex-aequo
avec six points sur 10
exactement et il y avait quatre derniers
ex-aequo avec quatre et demi sur 10 4
points 14 2 points d'écart entre les
premiers et les seconds il me semble je
suis pas sûr je sais plus non a priori
non entrés au oui non a priori non sinon
ça ne collerait pas en tout cas du
scandale mon garry kasparov là il hésite
on se demande pourquoi
qu'est ce qui se passe dans la tête du
champion peut-être qu'il n'a pas choqué
et ses cinq passes qu'il a vu que
cramique avait mieux que jouer suite il
ne veut pas risquer kasparov in the box
il est pas bien garry kasparov au à oô
ohanyan longari catoire village en moins
voire garino gary les lie down under est
assez surprenant voilà alors là on
retrouve dugarry fighter garric de la
nuit à j'ai joué le coup à fond kramnik
évident il veut faire trop prendre et
saigne ses suivants ce n'est pas sûr
stéphane sais pas c'est tout sauf sur il
peut jouer de bien comprendre peut jouer
puis reprend des cinq qui est un coup
sérieux dans la vision celle par exemple
de garder la paire de fou et de mettre
la pression sur lyon 2 je pense que plus
on prend des cinq est un meilleur coup
dans cette position et surtout ça libère
l'année granal du fou s'est vite
ah oui c'est possible par dans deux
possibilités ici pour vladimir kramnik
maintenant d'enseignants d'août a été
surpris à iwuy surcoût surprenante
kasparov qui met la pression son crâne
michele décidément vous pensez que ça
allait faire une partie nulle et bien
c'est sûr que non maintenant des joueurs
vont jouer jusqu'au bout
kasparov essaie de mettre la pression
sur kramnik alors c'est aux surprenants
il propose faut prendre 5 et 6 kramnik
pian le prendre avec les pions il va
sûrement ensuite posé sa tour sur la
case et 8 faisant une pression sur deux
et le flux s'est vite va pouvoir sortir
sur la démo nal malheureusement ça donne
aussi à kasparov la possibilité de
mettre son cari les c4 maintenant
désormais sur la case b6 et voilà tout
de suite ça met le feu à l'échiquier est
d'ailleurs une voie puisque est
d'ailleurs en juin il y a beaucoup de
flèches peut-être ça serait plus
explicite de jouer les coups stéphane
eux prend des cinq ici est envisagé je
pense que c'est le bon coup alors on va
alors non on va jouer auprès des cinq
tout simplement stéphane ça enlèvera les
flèches automatiquement on va jouer eux
prendre les 5
voilà qui est une possibilité est là
probablement class 40 jours
dans ce cas la cave des bêtises et 6 et
là on verrait bien coup comme fou g4
éventuellement ou faut aussi trouver 4 à
l'air d'être réfutées par trois ce n'est
pas réfuter mais c'est possible
peut-être fois je crois est fou h3c
attention cramique va jouer il va jouer
un échec pour le tour mais pas fou
chronique pour 30 des cinq pas
d'affaiblissement
ici il ya rica sport va se précipiter
sur kameni des siciliens aucun doute là
dessus et va vous pouvez tout de suite
ce qui va nous attendre à avoir cueilli
les six cas ce problème ne peut rien
jouer d'autres hélas les blancs on
al'impression les blancs vont réussir à
pénétrer sur la colonne c'est
puisqu'après cavale et b6 pour 17 serait
une faute
à toulouse deux cavaliers partout à
cause de câbles et pouf effectivement
aaa costard off line faire un signe non
de la tête il n'avait pas prévu ce tour
prendre des 500 me tillie l'avait plutôt
envisagé puis on prend des 5
oui est ce possible oui c'est tout à
fait possible que kasparov évidemment
quand il n'y a que deux coups possibles
non envisage comme ça serait grave si
t'es sport s'est trompé alors qu'il
pouvait faire nul très facilement en
répétant les cours se retrouve dans une
situation chronique pourrait reprendre
l'avantagé et le [ __ ] la pression à
stéphane ces fameux regard sur cabanes
et des six il a oublié je sais ce qui
l'obligé galerie castor il a oublié ou
bien un jour b5 tourbe et cela ne
revient pas oublier extrêmement fort en
b 5
oui mais tombé 5 sa menace non mais là
les pièces de castors sont englués
stéphane apprécié nord il peut jouer un
tour c'est un nom le cadet des trois
étangs président aime et fais le fou ces
huit aussi oui mais l'option b 2 aussi
oui mais et oui et oui c'est un problème
c'est un gros problème ici 15h30 et là
je voudrais dans la boîte j'ai un micro
qui malheureusement qui défaille c'était
normal c'est normal c'est le
c'est le matériel c'est le fameux micro
en boîte de conserve
on rappelle qu'ici nous faisons tout la
réal avec les moyens du bord
des webcams et réalisateur trouvait dans
un paquet bonux réalisateur de choc
puisqu'il nous vient de bastia en corse
et qu'il a le sens très chaud donc
stéphane je t'invite à ne pas dire
n'importe quoi
et oui sinon ça va chauffer rappelons
que tu habites à bordeaux et que ça
pourrait donner des idées à notre real
donc tombé 5 peut-être envisagée par
vladimir kramnik alors kasparov 9 après
vraisemblement pas jouer qui avait si
stéphane puisque ça serait une faute
grave
revenons sur la position quelques coupes
précédemment alors revenons sur la
position actuelle
voilà la position actuelle ici une
énergie kasparov fait mimiques sur
mimiques
il a oublié quelque chose il s'est
tourné vers nous on l'a vraiment ne suis
pas pour ce qu'il est oublié non mais il
ya forcément remise est tombé harrington
c'est peut-être quelque chose d'un peu
plus profond que le gars il n'a pas vu
en tout cas improbable les divers tronic
se lève maintenant facilité pour l'heure
la la la la la la
mais c'est en croatie car si vous passez
par on s'est gouré non mais kasparov on
sait bien qu'ils jouent au poker il nous
bluffe une double file a prévu un coup
ma suisse est probable stéphane
il faut se calmer quelques instants
garry kasparov ou le chauffeur et le
garry kasparov
il utilise toute sa panoplie de mimiques
et nuit alors que mon micro de micro est
tout à fait anormal regarde ses fans
regardent c'est un peu là garry kasparov
non mais c'est incroyable il vient de
jouer un coup évident kramnik a répondu
par le coup le plus simple possible
hélas kasparov qui sinue arima kasparov
encore mais c'est que c'est totalement
incroyable ce qui se passe vraiment
qu'est ce qui se passe vraiment garry
kasparov
est-ce que crâne on aurait pris un coup
de vieux oui et est-ce que cramique
known as pas 6,5 et maintenant tous ces
malheurs de ces images 110 pages sont
tout à fait il a l'air de pas être un
métier pourquoi il a fait faut prendre
des 5 alors il a donné son fou qui quand
même été merveilleux quand un cavalier
défensif et là dans les 16 mètres est ce
qu'on peut dire que je vais devenir
chronique dans toutes les parties
dominerait garry kasparov
oooh attention parce que stéphane
peut-être le cac scor en fait vu nulle
force est ici est en tout cas penser
avoir des possibilités bien il n'en a
pas il est donc déçu de ne faire que nul
nous convions tous rire comme je ne vois
pas comment je ne vois pas comment il
peut envisager de faire du lit si garry
kasparov et moins bien la teneur si les
cinq pour les tours et autant il finit
par attraper chronique puisque il y aura
quarante minutes contre 34 à kramnik
pour jouer dix sept coups et donc ça
risque éventuellement de devenir chaud
faut rappeler que chronique à la paire
de fou et que si kramnik arrive à sortir
sont fous ces huit ça va faire mal
après une poussée centrale de crâne ni
qui peut encore pousser de 5,4 et mettre
le feu sur l'échiquier dans mes
chroniques à des clans qui notamment
effectivement je vois bien le coup eux
58.6 c'est la première chose ensuite
tombé 5 et lagaf' peroff sera
complètement ils usent les g dic mais
qu'est-ce qui la fécasnau pourquoi il a
joué cette variante bidon alors qu'il
avait là nul en poche c'est hallucinant
ce qui est en train de se passer ils
sont nos yeux en direct au riverside
finaux de londres esquisse un vrai qu on
est devant nous un kasparov en fin de
règne alors autre possibilité
on aura entendu parler d'un sosie de
garry kasparov
une personne qui se ferait passer pour
garry kasparov qui jouerait assez bien
aux échecs mais quand même moins bien
que notre champion de grandes énigmes
qui s'appellerait gorica spa russe
gorica sparus ce qui est peut-être un
décor de théâtre le vrai kasparov et
peut-être museler actuellement dans sa
chambre à moscou à moscou et ici ils
n'auraient donc un sosie un sosie un
sosie de sa mère un sosie de seconde ont
en tout cas kasparov n'est que l'ombre
de lui-même
on lui aurait même mis des programmes de
canal web en direct et il se voit à la
télé en ce moment là ni carla kasparov
en train de faire faute sur faute
il est donc très surpris de ce qui se
passe en direct de moscou
c'est un supplice chinois
mais aucun doute c'est cela le vrai
garry kasparov qu'on a aujourd'hui à le
rôle de mauvais alors il semblerait
qu'il faille glee jantes et une enquête
auprès des instances compétentes
l'instant selon downing c'est-à-dire ce
canton scotland yard de scotland yard
et il semblerait je pense qu'avec une
analyse simple d'empreintes nous
arriverons à la solution est il même une
analyse
et oui et une analyse en tout cas une
analyse ici qui est celle de diagonale
ce ne serait pas de vrais caracas par
aof
c'est obligé c'est clair que cet homme
qui veut se faire passer pour le
champion du monde ça peut pas être lui
oui oui mais on est plus bluffé du tout
c'est clair que c'est pas le bon
kasparov puisque les mimiques de caspar
ans en général sont plutôt des mimiques
de quelqu'un qui gagne aux échecs et pas
de quelqu'un qui a l'air de faire des
gaffes et donc là on vient forcément ici
en face de nous un cadeau bonux nouvelle
génération le go russe tass paru ce qui
serait un sosie android 2 4 ans qui pose
alors holla holla holla stéphane là
c'est vraiment incroyable c'est la
fameuse mimiques qu'il avait employée
contre un monde alors qu'il donnait une
pièce il avait fait le même mouvement
exactement le même
il se penche la tête en arrière et
savent ça veut dire c'est synonyme de
gaffes de cafop celui des riads au maroc
qu'on va tout à fait noter ce moment-là
important du match là je crois que là la
mise en arrière de kasparov sur ce
mouvement très technique que yannick
notre réalisateur choc va nous montrer
au ralenti tout de suite il ne l'a pas
ratée yannick c'est sûr mais de montrer
au ralenti cc c'est un mouvement très
incroyable là haut tout cas il sera dans
le best of c'est sûr dans le best-of les
highlights les meilleurs moments de ce
match garry kasparov a tombé la tête la
caisse preuves matérielles
bien qu'un sport vont en tout cas
l'homme qui se fait passer pour garry
kasparov
je crois que là la question mérite
d'être posée une rumeur va commencer à
courir ici à londres
ça ne serait pas le grand kasparov
champion du monde depuis 15 ans mais son
sosie voire même son frère car si ce
n'est pas lui
donc qu'est donc son frère effectivement
il s'agirait d'un prototype point par le
gouvernement russe
ça se saurait vous allez être étonnés
ils été cloné salaires youtube kasparov
qu'ils ont sorti des chambres froides
celui même qui devait battre fisher et
qu'on avait remplacé par un prototype
karpov à l'époque il semblerait que ce
soit un vieux prototype
peut-être que le vrai que ce parent fait
en réparation et loi peut-être peut-être
que suite à une avarie des moteurs
puisqu'on vous rappelle que kasparov et
un cyborg et on l'avait déjà dit hier
kasparov ne peut pas calculer autant la
nomination de stéphane faisons peut-être
un bilan position comme pour étayer nos
arguments un petit peu je dirais
l'étrange les surprenants si on ne voit
pas le plaisir on ne peut pas comprendre
ce qu'on entend dire exactement garry
kasparov montrons son dernier coup à oui
on va remontrer tout à fait en arrière
nous allons nous le montrer aux
rallonges dans cette position kasparov
pourrait répéter la position et avoir la
nuit le tranquillement en jouant le coup
de cavaliers c5 proposant un crâne
nicklas nul et repoussant le combat plus
tard il a joué un coup tout à fait
surprenant qui a surpris tout le monde y
compris cramique après le coup
surprenant sous prendre des cinq granité
répondu sans broncher quasiment
immédiatement pour propio tour propre
champions et là on a l'impression que
que kasparov a donné son foot ou rien et
là kasparov tombe la tête dit cassé la
hanche en dans la terre il semblerait
qu'il ait vu quelque chose qui n'existe
pas il aurait fait mauvais calcul
ce qui justifie notre théorie ça ne
serait pas kasparov qui joue mais son
frère ou son sosie
l'un des deux en tout cas catllar of a
l'air vraiment hausse est remis tous
dans une petite pièce un écureuil
on va leur expliquer pourquoi avouer
qu'à dakar doit où la paire de fois on
va la montre et il a deux fous contre
deux cavaliers de fous ici contre deux
cavaliers et ça c'est un gros avantage
en finale notamment si les noirs
arrivent à ouvrir la position et on sait
que la la structure des pions et tels
que ça va être relativement facile pour
les noirs de créer des tensions alors on
peut peut-être expliquer effectivement
s'il ya des joueurs qui sont un petit
peu débutants ou en tout cas qui ne
jouent pas souvent en échec la valeur
des pièces ont dit que la dame vaut 10
points
donc les dames ont été échangés et
personne n'en a la tour 5 points le
foudre est à peu près trois et demi et
le cavalier 3 on donne un avantage d'un
fou contraint kameni d'à peu près égal à
1,2 million sachant que l'option étant
l'unité de mesure et s'attend alors à
condition que la position est un
caractère ouvert tout à fait il ya
certaines questions les cavaliers sont
plus forts que les fous mais il ya aussi
des positions par exemple un calibre
elle plus fort qu'un tour et là il
semblerait que crâne il va pouvoir
tourner tard jouer un plan à base de e65
f5 et ensuite eu 4 qui va ouvrir la
position est donc donné une force assez
fou wife et rieur à celle des cavaliers
à noter que la tour en dessins qui a une
case superbe
c'est la case des cinq ça c'est très
très important dans cette position ici
musc une fois qu'elle sera postée ici
elle attaquera simultanément les pions à
5 et p2 évidemment à 5 m et 2 seront
sous le fond de la tour voilà ça c'est
important
c'est très important kasparov aurait
fait encore une fois une gaffe une kayad
commis hier le coup tout rachat ou même
le coup cavaliers h4 hier on a eu droit
à deux petites gaffes de kasparov que
chronique a raté malheureusement c'est
tout à fait incroyable
garry kasparov l'homme y dominent la
planète échec depuis 15 ans ici fait une
faute digne d'un débutant
peut-être pas une débutante quand même
mais dean amateurs peut-être pas non
plus digne d'un semi professionnel
peut-être voilà en tout cas une fraude
grave à son niveau ça c'est sûr voilà
surtout quand on connaît la technique de
vladimir kramnik alors je vous invite
tous à l'univers de donner un fou comme
ça c'est ça que parce que non mais ce
qui s'est passé cette attention kasparov
évidemment c'est que quand il donne un
fou ces responsables c'est une avec
intérêts ils s'étaient rendu compte
qu'ils s'étaient trompés
voilà il a calculé quelque chose mais
kramnik en dessous comme ne régit pas du
tout il n'y a pas du tout peur il n'y a
pas de bluff avec rami travnik krainik
ricol rigole dans sa loge en ce
moment-même khaldun sa loge kramnik
esclaffé actuellement est ce qu'on peut
voir peut-être un plan d'ensemble de la
table pour indiquer à ceux qui nous
rejoignent en cours de route qui nous
ralentir en vue cet espace parents va
jouer comme elle sont des loges
moi je propose la casse arômes a joué le
coup km et 6 et surtout b5 et ça change
des cinq favoris garde est guéri 14 qui
apparemment a retrouvé son sang froid
voilà alors les loges sont à gauche et à
droite là où vous voyez les logos canal
web à gauche et à droite il y a les
notes des joueurs garry kasparov à sa
loge à gauche de l'écran
là vous déplacer et plaide pierre
chronique à sallanches à droite et
derrière cet échiquier bleus ce superbe
échiquier il ya vos serviteurs stéphane
laborde et moi-même qui sommes en train
de commenter ses portes d'ici explique
donc que quand on fait trop de bruit de
garry kasparov se tourner vers le haut
donc là par exemple nous allons faire
une simulation stéphane tu va pousser un
cri et nous allons voir en direct c'est
nous qui faisons l'événement garry
kasparov qui se tourne o o
il a réagit il à général kasparov
mais pas comme on l'attendait non mais
là alors donc est ce que les idées de
dépit il a dévidé mais c'est incroyable
alors est ce qu'on peut voir la position
de l'échiquier voit la démonstration
là on propose donc on pourrait sparrow
phrase jouer le cavalier en b 6 il y
aurait tourné autour des cinq attaquants
ici contre attaquant le cavalier en b3
hélas que le sport peut pas quand même
pas prendre le cavalier ans et 8 heures
et peut prendre le flou assez vite mais
après tout repenser vite il
complètement perdre ce que cavani prend
ses huit tours penser vite les noirs
récupère la colonne c'est et menace de
jouer un autre du tour ces détours ces
deux menaces qui va attaquer à la fois
le pion aux deux le pion b2 et ça y est
les noirs en probablement petit avantage
alors avec eux alors que gary n'a
toujours pas joué que si on fait un
bilan pendule il lui reste trente
minutes et 35 akram nick donc ça s'est
inversé à la pendule stéphane gary
kasparov et peut-être à la régie plus
kasparov jouer tranquillement le coup
cavalière d2 menaçant de mettre son
cavalier sur la classe c 4 avec un beau
duo de cavaliers finalement après le duo
de saumon il y à l'audio kevin autres
cavaliers et on pourrait pousser à
prépare probablement dont je sais pas
90e on pourrait pas le pousser en force
ce n'est pas grave mais on peut très
bien après échanges et ans et 8 et
remettre en cage béante des six camps
tout à fait alors ici effectivement
c'est sans doute ça que garry kasparov
en train de regarder
alors on va revenir la position réelle
puisque dans ces pays souhaitent
intéressante hausse des commandes
génétique est réel je pense qu'on va
rester peut-être nord-est ont peut-être
dans l'opposition quand même en convient
de mentionner pour vous la res est
variée on va remontrer cette variante
alors voilà on va revenir donc ici ici
direct par jour et cavaliers b6 cavalli
b6 de kasparov la cram ne répondrai pas
retombée cinq tours b cinq attaques
lequel des trois et après cavaliers
n'ont pas québec on s'est vite mes
cavaliers tedo qu'à valider de ici qui
semble être le bon coup avec l'idée de
venir sur la case c4 et la galerie
castorf a vu quelque chose qui le
contrarie
on ne sait pas ce que c'est ça a l'air
pas mal en fait quand mon plan
c'est clair puisque le fou s'est vite
peut toujours être pris par les blancs
mais la tombe et 5 fait une pression sur
b2 qui mobilise les tours blanches
oui mais quand le club d'istres en c4 le
kawaï et défendra les d'options
effectivement qu'est-ce qui peut
contrarier kasparov dans cette
possibilité là bas c'est la paire de fou
non la peur de foot non puisqu'on va
prendre le fossé alors qu'il s'agit du
retour du grand jérôme sol à quillan qui
va pouvoir nous faire un commentaire sur
ce qui se passe actuellement
stéphane je propose que tu nous laisses
puisque nous sommes dans un petit espace
que le micro vient de tomber
mais ce n'est pas grave puisque l'
aventure celle aventure je vous invite
d'ailleurs à regarder cette émission sur
le canal web et sur présentés par claire
gibault que nous saluons au passage
voilà je vais passer le micro à jérôme
thion rebonjour jérôme re bonjour à tous
alors qu'elle était le thème de vos
derniers commentaires
eh bien nous supposions qu'il s'agissait
d'un sosie de garry kasparov
alain et que ce n'était pas le vrai gars
qui pouvaient jouer un coup comme fou
prend des cinq coups qui paraît quand
même complètement aberrant jérôme tu
seras d'accord avec moi
ceux ci on a l'impression qu'il ya pas
d'autre moyen de progresser vraiment
parce qu'il y avait des 5 contre pas mal
de casse mais je sais c'est vrai qu'on a
l'impression que ça passe plus trop là
mais donc est ce que tu as vu castro qui
s'est renversée proprement son échiquier
j'ai pas eu droit à saint-anicet il
s'est penché l'adaptant à l'esa j'ai vu
mon signalement la verrière à l'agonie
comme d'habitude comme d'habitude à
noter que leila il n'a plus que 27
minutes
bonjour 35 pour chroniques vraiment pas
les reins pas là bien satisfaire parce
que vous regardiez comme plan mais ici
on regardait comme unique possibilité si
on peut montrer notre échiquier
nous allons rappeler quelques variantes
ici
cavani b6 alain tourbez 5 et maintenant
le coût cavaliers en d2 alors peut-être
là-dessus parce que vous regardiez on
peut jouer des plans avec avec 5 sur mon
alors eu cette hausse un tweak amené
prend ses beats on éliminerait foot ou
reprend et maintenant les qualités d'un
grand c4 menaçant la fourchette en d6 ce
qui est important effectivement un pas
rater on va rater dès maintenant pas si
facile forcément à peut-être un plan ici
j'ai ce pas ce que tu en penses verront
peut-être fuite avec l'idée de jouer
fouan b4 et tours s'est vite en cessant
avec donkey pineau draine pion à 5 alors
tous ces huit c5 et pourquoi pas en fait
déjà foulé fuite c'est un bon coup
défensives c'est à contrôler toutes les
casses empêche mais quatre pour le
moment ça contrôler la case des six jeux
plan to b 4e tour c'est simple c'est
possible c'est peut-être ça qui fait
peur et garry kasparov peut-être ne
s'est rendu compte de ça parce
qu'effectivement si on regarde cette
pression objectivement apparemment les
blancs auraient une position très solide
avec un calice et 4 vient d'implanter ça
c'est possible mais bon on est les noirs
ont bien contrôlé toutes les 15 à enfin
la casse des six surtout oui pürro 5
protégé par la tour axa à ballarat très
facile pour les membres six positions
non ça paraît clair que les noirs ont un
petit avantage ici est mort
voilà la position actuellement sur
l'échiquier
tu as été surpris par tout le monde est
sain et qui n'ont en fait je pensais que
c'était un coup normal à vrai dire mais
mais c'est vrai quand on voit la
position c'est le plus tôt la position
qui s'en prend à l'impression qu'un plus
grand chose et que encore comme un
tesson comme on dit qu ils peuvent nous
réserver des grands moments de kasparov
mais bon lui même at a l'air très très
très convaincu par son jeu c'est vrai
qu'il aurait encore raté son coup
chronique est très concentré quand même
chronique à l'air tranquille mais
chronique en plus quand on a vu c'est
parti on voit qu'avec la paire de fully
fait des miracles ont effectivement pire
on le voit mal perdre une partie comme
ça quand même
ah oui ça me regarde pas une position
vraiment pas une façon pour 80 alala
alors que nous avons du nouveau matériel
la course technologique chez grasset
ligne à canal web
effectivement ça ne marche toujours pas
mais ce n'est pas grave
au moins le matériel et renouveler très
beaux plans simples ans les deux cas
face à face c'est rare quand même qu'ils
se promènent plutôt pas mal mais bon
c'est vrai que
je
les joueurs sont passés vers
affreusement égal à nant dans les
morceaux où la bourse a nettement mieux
nettement mieux ah bah oui il ya de fous
quand même comme je regardais la
perspective ans dans la position blanche
j'avais pas l'idée que je pouvais être
plus mal déjà manquantes ou kaka sport
enfin palard pouvoir gagner sa position
non mais là c'est une certitude
maintenant c'est les noirs qui sont
mieux je pense qu' il n'y a aucun doute
là dessus on voit pas comment garry
kasparov peut s'en sortir
enfin si on suppose que garry kasparov
fierté devant fois de la voilà encore
une fois il a secoué la tête
frénétiquement une n'arrête pas de
secouer la tête jerry kasparov
c'est vrai un coup musclé donc alors
c'est peut-être pour ça qui fait ton aux
sports voit nommé jérôme rappelons quand
même que tu es un très bon joueur de
poker et que donc tu peux lire sur la
tête des gens alors ici que guy tu sur
le visage de garry kasparov
mais le problème avec cast offs et qui
grimace tout le temps en fait alors
l'adversaire joue un bon coup de gris
mat l'adversaire joue un mauvais coup il
grimace donc en fait apparemment quand
tu joues autre chose que ce qu'il a vu
de toutes façons c'est la mairie basse
c'est pas évident et d'ailleurs quand on
voit ce qu'il a vu aussi des fois ouais
effectivement on sait pas trop quoi
faire pour qu'il garde une quête normal
en fait certitude c'est qu'il n'y aurait
pas beaucoup d'argent poker blement et
oui c'est sûr mais en tout cas ils en
gagnent pas mal aux échecs jusqu'au delà
si il y à d'un million de dollars de
prix mais malheureusement peut-être
qu'après le match si ça continue il va
falloir se reconvertir cavaliers bd de
chevet par garry kasparov cavalli bd2 un
coup capitule à thouars dans le sens
ou entre amis comics the tempo ses yeux
les superbes alors que voilà nous avons
une tête rousse qui pointe à l'horizon
et nul le bout de son nez ils ont fait
nul ils ont fait nul à mais c'est aussi
une vielle de faire nul voilà qu'elle
sera organisée garry kasparov
complètement maîtrisée dont le cinq
trams nick a proposé nul on attendait à
ce qu ils aient envie de jouer un petit
peu et en fait non il a fait nul donc
nous allons dans quelques instants
assister à la conférence de presse je
vais laisser stéphane laborde vous
expliquer ce qui va se passer puisque il
sait très bien faire ça
voilà les joueurs sont en train de
commenter cette partie cet étonnant que
kramnik accepte la nulle propose même
nul alors que on avait l'impression que
kasparov avait laissé l'initiative à
cramique les joueurs vont nous rejoindre
venger la scène d'ici quelques minutes
pour commenter cette partie et répondre
aux questions des journalistes cette
soirée était une partie probablement la
moins tendues depuis le début du match
parti qui aura duré
un peu moins de trois heures à peu près
trois heures
voilà l'arbitré éric schiller américain
il ya trois arbitres ce match dont il
est co schiller qui ont mêlé pièces sur
l'échiquier
les joueurs vont donc rejoindre la scène
pour répondre aux questions des
journalistes
encore une fois kramnik a repoussé assez
facilement
l'initiative des blancs dans l'ouverture
et
malheureusement n'aura pas droit
aujourd'hui un combat commis hier le
grande partie hier probablement la plus
belle depuis le début du match même si
le résultat était nul le parti ou que
cramique aurait pu gagner s'ils avaient
vu notamment tour g8 en fin de partie
hélas aujourd'hui parties nulles
probablement dues en partie à cause de
la fatigue des joueurs puisque la
fatigue joue hier plus de six heures
trente de jeu et il faut enchaîner
aujourd'hui avec cette partie jamais
facile et la casse parviennent une
nouvelle fois de grillé une de ses
cartouches avec les blancs chronique
maintenant mardi va reprendre
l'initiative avec les pièces blanches
étonnant que crâne n'est pas jouer cette
partie
chronique aurait pu aujourd'hui encore
une fois mettre la pression sur kasparov
qui a joué un coup probablement douteux
ne vous prend qu'à valider cinq très
belle défense encore une fois de granny
qu'aujourd'hui je rappelle que après la
conférence de presse des joueurs nous
procédons à 2 petit résumé de la journée
le premier en anglais proposé par danny
king commentateurs anglais a suivi
ensuite d'un résumé en français
ces résumés disponible en différé dans
les émissions diagonale de canal web
il vous suffit de cliquer sur les
boutons vidéo il optique et sur le
bouton archives vidéo pour avoir accès à
toutes les archives de diagonale y
compris toutes les émissions qui sont
été fait est enregistrée depuis deux ans
les émissions hebdomadaires et la
retransmission des grands prix voilà les
joueurs maintenant ce sont sur scène
ils vont répondre aux questions des
journalistes le micro de kasparov a
devant nous avant ce combat qu'il faut
ah non il faut un homme
le petit la nôtre ailleurs
the time for lashes
d
votre barre des 10
la commune et par mes origines je peux
aider les autres dans votre pâte ni
briatte nos basics nous pas ton cas de
costinha 4 pds à partir option douaniers
associatif